Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory turned his attention to the injured man. He was a mere stripling, with the delicate features of a woman, and a pair of great violet-blue eyes, which looked up presently with a puzzled stare into Nigel's face. Who are you? he asked. Ah, yes, I call you to mind.
感谢收听《历史的余烬》。要想每周收听独家加更节目、无广告音频、系列节目的抢先收听权限，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory 把注意力转向了这个受伤的人。他只是个瘦弱的年轻人，有着女人般秀气的外表，一双大大的紫蓝色眼睛，此刻正带着一丝困惑的目光抬头看着奈杰尔的面孔。“你是谁？”他问，“啊，是的，我想起来了。”
You are the young Englishman who chased me on the great yellow horse. By our lady of Rocamador, whose vernicle is round my neck. I could not have believed that any horse could have kept to the heels of Charlemagne so long, but I will wager you a hundred crowns, Englishman, that I lead you over a five-mile course.
“你就是那个骑着高大黄马追赶我的年轻英国人。凭着挂在我脖子上的罗卡马杜圣母圣容布，我绝不相信世间有哪匹马能这么长时间紧咬着查理曼的脚后跟不放，但我跟你打个赌，英国人，赌一百克朗，我敢带你在五英里的赛道上跑一圈。”
Nay, said Nigel. Sounds like a horse. Nay, said Nigel. We will wait until you can back a horse. There we talk of racing it. I am Nigel of Tilford, of the family of Loring, a squire by rank and the son of a knight. How are you called, young sir? I am also a squire by rank and the son of a knight. I am Raoul de la Roche Pierre de Bras, whose father writes himself Lord of Grosbois, a free vavasor of the noble count of Toulouse, with the right of fossa and of furca, the high justice, the middle and the low. He sat up and rubbed his eyes. Englishman, you have saved my life as I would have saved yours had I seen such yelping dogs set upon a man of blood and of coat armour but now I am yours, and what is your sweet will? When you are fit to ride, you will come back with me to my people
“不，”奈杰尔说。“听起来倒像匹马。不，”奈杰尔说。“等你能骑马了再说。那时候我们再来谈赛马的事。我是蒂尔福德的奈杰尔，出自洛林家族，论阶级是个随从，也是一名骑士的儿子。年轻人，尊姓大名？”“按阶级我也是个随从，也是一位骑士的儿子。我叫拉乌尔·德·拉罗舍·皮埃尔·德·布拉斯，我父亲自称格罗布瓦领主，是图卢兹贵族伯爵辖下一个自由封臣，享有高等、中等和低等司法裁判权。”他坐起身，揉了揉眼睛。“英国人，你救了我的命，若是我看到有一群狂吠的恶犬扑向一个身负血统与纹章铠甲的人，我也会救你的命。既然我现在是你的人了，您的尊意如何？”“等你伤好能骑马了，就跟我回我的人那儿去。”
Alas, I had feared that you would say so Had I taken you, Nigel, that is your name, is it not? Had I taken you, Nigel, that is your name, is it not? Had I taken you, I would not have acted thus. So Tom Holland, that is Sir Arthur Conan Doyle's novel. Beautifully written, as usual. Sir Nigel, both beautifully written, and I think it's fair to say remarkably read. Beautifully read, yeah. Those readings from Sir Nigel with which we're introducing our epic sweep through the Hundred Years' War,
“唉，我真怕你会这么说。要是我抓住了你，奈杰尔，那是你的名字，对吧？要是我抓住了你，奈杰尔，那是你的名字，对吧？要是我抓住了你，我可不会这么做。”这就是小汤姆·霍兰德，也就是阿瑟·柯南·道尔的小说。一如既往，文笔优美。《骑士奈杰尔》，不仅文笔优美，而且我认为完全可以说朗读得也非常出色。朗读得很棒，是的。我们用《骑士奈杰尔》中的这些片段来引出我们对百年战争的史诗级全景回顾，
Arthur Conan Doyle always thought they were better than the Sherlock Holmes books. And he was gutted, wasn't he, that people paid so much attention to Holmes and not enough to Nigel. And actually, although we are, it's fair to say we're not reading them, well, I'm not reading them with an entirely straight face. They do capture the sort of sense of the Hundred Years' War as this great gallant chivalric. Yes. Yes, as a bit of a game. I mean, it probably didn't seem that way to the blind king of Bohemia when he was riding the wrong way. Well, no, but it did.
阿瑟·柯南·道尔一直认为它们比福尔摩斯系列小说还要好。而且他当时非常郁闷，不是吗？因为人们把那么多的注意力都给了福尔摩斯，却没有给予奈杰尔足够的关注。事实上，尽管我们在读这些书——可以这么说，我们并不是完全板着脸在读它们，嗯，我读的时候可没法完全保持严肃——但它们确实捕捉到了百年战争那种宏大、英勇、崇尚骑士精神的氛围。是的。是的，就像是一场游戏。我的意思是，当盲眼的波希米亚国王骑着马逆行时，他可能并不觉得这是一场游戏。嗯，话虽如此，但当时确实是这样的。
It did because he died a chivalric death. Yes, that's fair. And the codes of chivalry are still very important in this period. And one of the things that's interesting about the Hundred Years' War and makes it significant is the way that it starts to mutate those codes, both because they are used very, very powerfully by both French and English kings and knights, but also because of the impact of the way that the English fight, which starts to diminish the rank and the status of the traditional knightly classes. Well, we ended last time by talking about the Battle of Crecy, didn't we?
确实如此，因为他是以骑士的方式死去的。是的，这倒也是。而且骑士准则在这一时期依然非常重要。关于百年战争有一个有趣且使其意义重大的方面，那就是它开始改变这些准则。一方面是因为法国和英国的国王与骑士们非常、非常有力地利用了这些准则，另一方面也是因为英军作战方式的影响，这种影响开始削弱传统骑士阶层的阶级和地位。嗯，我们在上一集结尾时聊到了克雷西战役，不是吗？
And the longbow and military technology. You know, there are arguments that it's even the first modern battle because it's won by projectiles rather than by people fighting hand to hand. But on the other thing about the Sir Nigel spirit of gallantry and chivalry. So listeners who heard the first two episodes will recall that we went through the origins of the war, Edward III launching this sort of preemptive strike almost on France, the great superpower of Europe, and then winning these tremendous battles at Sluice and then at taking Calais and Crecy. But all of that happens against the backdrop of this looming catastrophe with which we ended last time, which is the advent of the Black Death. So we had this amazing moment.
还有长弓与军事技术。你知道，有观点认为它甚至可以说是第一场现代战役，因为它是由抛射物而非近身肉搏来决定胜负的。不过关于《骑士奈杰尔》那种豪侠与骑士精神的另一个话题是：听过前两集节目的听众会记得，我们梳理了战争的起源，爱德华三世对当时欧洲超级大国法国发动了某种意义上的先发制人打击，随后在斯鲁伊斯以及后来的加来和克雷西赢得了这些辉煌的战役。但所有这一切发生的背景，都是我们上一集结尾时提到的一场迫在眉睫的灾难，那就是黑死病的降临。所以我们迎来了这样一个惊人的时刻。
Yeah. This is a ship pulls into Messina, dead men at the oars, the description in Barbara Tuchman's book, A Distant Mirror. So everything that we're going to talk about from now on happens against the backdrop that arguably one of the most devastating backdrops in Western history, which is the advent of the plague. Well, actually, Sir Nigel Conan Doyle's novel opens with a brilliant account of the Black Death coming. I mean, I don't remember much of what happens in Sir Nigel, but I do remember that opening. But the strange thing is, you were saying in our last episode that the Black Death changes everything. Obviously, on one level, it does. Up to a third of Europe's population gets wiped out. That is a catastrophe on an enormous, enormous scale. But at the same time, actually, in the context of the war,
是的。这是一艘驶入墨西拿港的船，桨手皆已死亡，正如巴巴拉·塔奇曼在她的书《远方之镜》中所描述的那样。因此，我们从今以后要讨论的一切，都发生在一个可以说是西方历史中最具毁灭性的背景之下，那就是瘟疫的降临。嗯，实际上，柯南·道尔的小说《骑士奈杰尔》一开篇，就对黑死病的到来进行了精彩的描绘。我的意思是，我不记得《骑士奈杰尔》里具体发生过多少事，但我确实记得那个开篇。但奇怪的是，你上一集说过黑死病改变了一切。显然，在某种层面上，它确实如此。欧洲多达三分之一的人口被消灭。这是一场规模极其宏大、极其巨大的灾难。但与此同时，实际上在战争的背景下，
it doesn't change very much. That's the strange thing. It brings a halt to the fighting. We said that the Black Death arrives in Europe a month or so after the capture of Calais. It's reached France that winter. It reaches England the following summer. People in Scotland are laughing, the English are all dying of it. Then it reaches Scotland and they all start dying of it as well. So it does definitely put a pause on the conflict, but it certainly doesn't bring it to an end. And it certainly doesn't stop Edward's war aims because essentially the Black Death serves to pause the conflict and Edward is in pole position because he has the upper hand militarily, but crucially, he also has the upper hand in terms of prestige. So this is a world, I mean, beautifully rendered by Conan Doyle and articulated in your reading, in which these codes do matter. And the person who can kind of lay claim to them and to present himself as the model of those codes is actually, that's a strong position to be in.
它并没有改变太多。这就是奇怪的地方。它让战事停顿了下来。我们说过，黑死病是在加来陷落一个月左右后传入欧洲的。它在那年冬天到达了法国，第二年夏天到达了英国。苏格兰人还在幸灾乐祸，而英国人却都在因此而死。接着瘟疫传到了苏格兰，他们也开始成批死去。所以它确实让冲突按下了暂停键，但它绝对没有让冲突彻底终结。它当然也没有阻止爱德华的战争目标，因为本质上黑死病只是起到了暂停冲突的作用，而爱德华处于绝对有利的地位，因为他在军事上占了上风，但更关键的是，他在声望上也占了上风。所以这是一个——我的意思是，经由柯南·道尔精妙呈现并在你的朗读中表达出来的——这样一个世界：在其中这些准则确实至关重要，而那个能够宣称自己继承了这些准则、并把自己塑造为这些准则化身的人，无疑占据了非常有利的地位。
So listeners who heard the first two episodes will know that Edward did not go to war because he wanted to be king of France. That ends up being a kind of justification or tactic during his war, but he goes to war really to protect his own realm from what he sees as inevitable French attack. That's right, isn't it? That's right. And his claim to the French throne is basically a kind of bargaining counter. Right. So here's the thing. Post-Cressy, does he still see it that way? Or does he now think, okay, I can actually do this. I could become king of France. I don't think so. I mean, he's a strategic genius. He understands the way that power works and armies work. And he, I think, appreciates the fact that he has no real prospect
听过前两集节目的听众会知道，爱德华发动战争并不是因为他想当法国国王。这最终成了他在战争期间的一种辩护方式或策略，但他发动战争实际上是为了保护自己的王国免受他所认为不可避免的法军进攻。对吧？是这样的。他对法国王位的宣称，基本上只是一种讨价还价的筹码。对。所以问题就在于：克雷西战役之后，他还是这么看的吗？还是说他现在觉得，好吧，我其实真的能做到这一点。我可以成为法国国王。我不这么认为。我的意思是，他是个战略天才。他理解权力和军队运作的方式。而且我认为他很清楚，自己实际上并没有可能
of conquering the whole of France. His aim is to use his claim to the French crown to leverage as many possessions as he can get out of the French king, and also crucially to get the French king to acknowledge that these possessions are sovereign. In other words, Edward will no longer have to pay homage to the French crown for these possessions. But obviously In other words, Edward will no longer have to pay homage to the French crown for these possessions. But obviously, he can't admit that because if he says that, then the whole scam fails. So he has to project himself as a potential king of France. And to do that, he has to present himself basically as the greatest king in Christendom, because that is his ambition. And he can do that because he is palpably a greater warrior and a kind of more
征服整个法国。他的目标是利用他对法国王冠的宣称，从法国国王那里尽可能多地勒索领地，更关键的是，让法国国王承认这些领地是享有主权的。换句话说，爱德华再也不用为这些领地向法国王室臣服效忠了。但显然，换句话说，爱德华再也不用为这些领地向法国王室臣服效忠了。但显然，他不能承认这一点，因为如果他这么说了，整个骗局就破产了。所以他必须把自己包装成一个潜在的法国国王。为了做到这一点，他必须把自己塑造成基督教世界中最伟大的国王，因为这就是他的野心。他能够做到这一点，是因为他显然是一个比腓力六世更伟大的统帅，是一个更具魅力、更耀眼的人物。腓力六世在克雷西战役战败后，显得黯然失色。而爱德华的目标——他极其成功地实现了这一目标，说来也怪，是在加来之围后、黑死病肆虐的时期——是将自己确立为统治着一个新卡米洛特的新亚瑟王，尽管他的战略从长远来看其效果恰恰是摧毁了他所极力阐述的那些骑士理想。这就是他统治时期的悖论。但我认为，毫无疑问，在克雷西和加来战役之后，英法两国即使在敌对状态因黑死病的爆发而暂停期间，也依然在争夺骑士荣耀的制高点。因此，关于这一点的一个事实是，骑士们几乎就是中世纪最接近体育明星的存在。这些是享有国际声誉的人物。因此，他们相对的地位确实至关重要。所以，法国人的标志性人物是一个名叫
glamorous, a more burnished figure than Philip VI, who's left very diminished by his defeat at Crecy. And Edward's aim, which he triumphantly fulfills, oddly, you know, in the aftermath of Calais, when the Black Death is raging, is to establish himself as a new King Arthur ruling over a new Camelot, even as his strategy, its long run effect will be to demolish the kind of the knightly ideals that he's articulating. So that's the paradox of his reign. But I think there's absolutely a sense in the wake of Crecy and Calais that England and France, even while hostilities have been paused by the onset of the Black Death, they are competing for the upper ground of chivalric glory. And so one of the things about this is that knights are the closest equivalent of sports stars that the Middle Ages have. These are figures with kind of international renown. And so their relative status does matter. So the emblematic figure for the French is a man
热奥弗鲁瓦·德·沙尔尼的人，他就像中世纪以来许多伟大的骑士一样，是勃艮第某位相对较小的贵族的第三子。但他崛起成为了法兰西骑士精神的绝对焦点。他之所以能做到这一点，是因为他基本上就是比武大会中的姆巴佩。他太出色了。没有梅西那么好，你是这意思吗？那个王子是梅西。对，我猜吧。我们一会儿再聊谁可能是梅西。
called Geoffrey de Charny, who, like so many of the great knights right the way through the Middle Ages, he's a third son of a relatively minor nobleman from Burgundy. But he rises to become the absolute cynosure of French chivalry. And he does that because he's basically the Mbappé of tournaments. He is superb. Not as good as Messi, is that your claim? That prince is Messi. Yeah, I guess. We'll come to who might be the Messi.
所以他做了所有一个骑士（Chevalier）该做的事。他去参加十字军东征。他撰写关于骑士精神要点的皇皇巨著。他阐明了一种观念：除了真正成为一名神父之外，当一名骑士是对上帝最好的侍奉。绝妙的是，他还是都灵裹布已知的第一位拥有者，这可以说是他独特的一个品质。但问题随之而来：这对法国有什么实际用途呢？你有这种骑士精神的楷模固然很好，但它真的能在军事上帮助法国吗？沙尔尼对此心知肚明。他对此感到焦虑。
So he does everything that a Chevalier should. He goes on a crusade. He writes tomes on points of chivalry. He articulates a sense that being a knight is the finest service that anyone can do to God outside of actually becoming a priest. And brilliantly, he's the first known owner of the Turin Shroud, which is kind of distinctive quality. But the question then is, what practical use is this to France? It's great that you have this kind of model of chivalry, but does it actually help France militarily? And Chani is aware of this. He's anxious about this.
因此他想为法兰西尽自己的一份力。于是在1349年末，在黑死病最严重的一波过去之后，他决定收复加来，因为他意识到加来是爱德华克雷西战役中最大的战略果实。他也意识到这是一项极其艰巨的任务，因为加来现在完全由英国人居住。这里驻扎着庞大无比的军队，是全欧洲军队最集中的地方。所以，那种像兰斯洛特爵士一样骑马冲过去就能把它拿下的想法简直是异想天开。沙尔尼也意识到了这一点。但他并不强求只用骑士精神的准则去发动一次全线冲锋。你知道，他也可以运筹帷幄，使用诡计
And so he wants to do his bit for France. And so late in 1349, after the kind of the worst of the Black Death has passed, he decides he's going to retake Calais because he appreciates that Calais is the great strategic fruit of Edward's Cressy campaign. And he also appreciates that this is a massive ask because Calais is now exclusively inhabited by English. It has this massive, massive concentration of troops, the largest concentration of troops anywhere in Europe. And so the idea that you can ride up to it like Sir Lancelot and, you know, take it out is fantastical. And Chani recognizes that. But he's not obliged by the codes of chivalry simply to launch a full-on charge. You know, he can deploy tricks
、谋略和战术。我的意思是，这完全是合法的。所以他采取的做法是，他接触了一位身在加来的意大利雇佣兵，一个名叫阿尔马里克·德·帕维亚的人，并向他提供了巨额贿赂。阿尔马里克把钱揣进口袋，说：“太棒了。我放你和你的法兰西部队进来。”接着阿尔马里克乘船渡过海峡，在平安夜来到爱德华的宫廷，向他禀报了这一切。而对爱德华来说，这简直是一份厚礼。
and schemes and reasons as well. I mean, that's perfectly legitimate. So what he does is he approaches an Italian mercenary who's in Calais, a guy called Almaric of Pavia, and offers him a big bribe. And Almaric pockets it and says, yeah, brilliant. I'll let you and your band of French troops in. Almaric then takes ship, crosses the channel, comes to Edward's court on Christmas Eve and tells him what's doing. But Edward, this is a massive Christmas present.
是的。多有意思啊。于是他、黑太子以及所有的小伙子们，全都放弃了圣诞庆典，乘船赶往加来。可怜的老沙尔尼根本不知道他们已经到达了那里。坦白说，他真的非常天真，汤姆。嗯，他是骑士精神的楷模嘛。阿尔马里克放了一支法国人的先头
Yeah. What fun. So him, the Black Prince, all the lads, they all abandon their Christmas festivities, take ship to Calais. Poor old Sharni has no idea that they've arrived there. He's very naive, I think it's fair to say, Tom. Well, he's a model of chivalry. Almaric lets a kind of advanced
部队进来，他们在城门上方升起了旗帜，然后他们就被全歼了。接着爱德华吹响了号角，他们全都（你知道的）被俘了，沙尔尼也被俘虏并被带到了英国。所以这一切非常尴尬，对吧？是的，爱德华大获全胜。与此同时，镜头转回法国，腓力六世（你知道的）他正在走下坡路，并于1350年8月去世，继位的是他的儿子约翰，也就是约翰二世。听众们可能还记得，约翰一世是个五岁的婴儿。哦天哪，是的。他统治了五天还是几天来着？对，对。说实话，约翰二世几乎和前任一样无能，他是个糟糕透顶的——所以他看起来像个国王，他留着胡须，我的意思是（你知道的）符合标准选角形象，
guard of the french in they raise the banner over the gateway and then they get wiped out and edward sounds the trumpets and they all get you know captured and the shiny gets taken prisoner goes to england so it's all very embarrassing right yeah and edward has triumphed meanwhile back in france philip the sixth is you know he's he's on his way out and he dies in uh in august 1350 and he's succeeded by his son john who becomes john the second your listeners may remember that john the first was the five-year-old baby oh gosh yeah he ruled for five days or something yeah yeah and to be honest john ii is pretty much as useless as he's a terrible so he looks like a king he's got a beard i mean you know central casting yeah but he's terrible he's kind of very insecure he's very obstinate and he's incredibly thick and if he's
但他糟透了。他非常缺乏安全感，极其顽固，而且笨得不可理喻。如果给他
given two options he will invariably choose the worst option and then kind of cling to it absolutely obdurately. Barbara Tuchman says of him that he could have served Machiavelli as the model for the anti-prince. So he's a terrible king, but because he looks like a king, he feels that he should have an order of chivalry that adequately reflects his desire to be the most Christian king. And fortunately for him, a year after he succeeded to the throne, so July 1351, Geoffrey de Charny comes back from England. He's been ransomed. And he is the guy, obviously, to advise the French king on setting up an order of chivalry. He's the perfect guy. So Geoffrey de Charny kind of draws up a rule book and this new order is to be called the order of the star. And it is enshrined in honor of God,
两个选择，他总是会毫不例外地选择最糟糕的那一个，然后极其顽固地坚持到底。巴巴拉·塔奇曼评价他说，他简直可以成为马基雅维利笔下“反君主”的原型。所以他是个糟糕的国王，但因为他长得像个国王，他就觉得应该建立一个骑士团，来充分体现他渴望成为“最基督化国王”的愿望。对他而言幸运的是，在他即位一年后，也就是1351年7月，热奥弗鲁瓦·德·沙尔尼从英国回来了。他被赎回了。显然，他就是指导法国国王建立骑士团的最佳人选。他是最完美的人选。于是热奥弗鲁瓦·德·沙尔尼起草了一套规章制度，这个新骑士团将被命名为“星空骑士团”（Order of the Star）。它的建立旨在荣耀上帝、
of our lady, and for the heightening of chivalry and augmenting of honor. Geoffrey de Charny writes a complete guidebook for it. But the measure of how much Geoffrey de Charny has been thinking about this and the reasons for English success is that although he is the great star of tournaments, what you have to do to win entry into the Order of the Star isn't success in tournaments, as had traditionally been the case with the Shafal Rig orders, but success in battle. So members have to come and report their deeds in battle to the king. And when they're enrolled in the order, they have to swear a solemn oath that they will never retreat from battle. They will stand their ground at all times. So this is the real thing. This is hardcore. This isn't flummering around with
荣耀圣母，并弘扬骑士精神、增进荣誉。热奥弗鲁瓦·德·沙尔尼为其撰写了一整本指南。但从热奥弗鲁瓦·德·沙尔尼对此事的深思熟虑以及对英国成功原因的分析中可以看出，尽管他是比武大会上的超级巨星，但要想获得星空骑士团的入场券，传统的骑士团通常看重的是在比武大会上的成功，而这里看重的却不是比武，而是在战场上的成功。因此，成员必须前来向国王报告他们在战场上的功绩。当他们被招入骑士团时，必须庄严宣誓：绝不从战场上撤退。无论何时都要坚守阵地。所以这动真格的了。这是硬核内容。这可不是什么女士吊袜带之类的花哨玩意儿。这是相当有骨气的。
garters for ladies and stuff. This is pretty gritty. That is absolutely right. And it's clearly an attempt to adapt to Geoffrey de Charnny's understanding that there is a new age and that if the French are to hold their own against the English, they need to basically not run away, which loads are done at Crecy. So this new order is proclaimed with lots of trumpets and hurrahs and things like that. But the problem is, I mean, it's a bit rubbish, really. Oh, no. How disappointing for the french of course you know the french court is the traditionally the model of chivalry but they have the first meeting in on the 6th of january 1352 and and basically not many people turn up
完全正确。这显然是一种调整，体现了热奥弗鲁瓦·德·沙尔尼的清醒认识：这是一个新时代，如果法国人要在与英国人的对抗中守住阵地，他们基本上就不能临阵脱逃——而这正是他们在克雷西战役中所做的事。于是，这个新骑士团在一片号角声和欢呼声中宣告成立。但问题是，说实话，它有点烂透了。哦，不。对法国人来说多么令人失望啊。当然，（你知道的）法国宫廷传统上是骑士精神的楷模，但他们在1352年1月6日召开了第一次会议，基本上没来几个人。
oh so very embarrassing and even more embarrassing is the fact that one of the knights who does turn up is a guy who is commanding one of the key castles next to Calais, so one of the French-held castles next to Calais. So he comes to this meeting, and while he's away, the English move in and grab his castle. So it's all mortifying. That's very funny. Makes me proud to be English, that is.
噢，这太尴尬了。更尴尬的是，唯一出席的一位骑士，恰好是负责加来附近关键城堡之一的指挥官——也就是加来附近少数几个由法国控制的城堡之一。所以他来开会了，而当他不在的时候，英国人趁虚而入，夺走了他的城堡。所以这一切简直丢脸至极。太搞笑了。这让我为身为英国人感到骄傲。
Absolutely. But Dominic, what should also completely make you proud to be English is the fact that one of the reasons why the Order of the Star seems a bit pallid is that it's nothing compared to the blaze of another order of chivalry that's just been set up. And that has been set up by Edward III in England. And it's an order of chivalry that is still going strong to this day. The order of the garter. See, I feel bad now because I made a disobliging remark about messing around with garters. But of course, the order of the garter is the top order of chivalry. Tom, if we play our cards right with this podcast, I mean, I don't think a historian has ever got the garter. Have they? Churchill got the garter. I think John Major has it. If John Major has the garter, you could reasonably aspire to that. Surely we can use it, can't we? Yeah.
绝对的。但是，多米尼克，同样完全应该让你为身为英国人感到骄傲的事实是：星空骑士团之所以显得有些黯然失色，原因之一在于它根本无法与刚刚建立的另一个骑士团的光芒相提并论。那是英格兰的爱德华三世建立的骑士团。而且这是一个直到今天依然长盛不衰的骑士团。加德骑士团（Order of the Garter）。你看，我现在觉得有点不好意思了，因为我刚才开玩笑说摆弄吊袜带很无聊。但当然，加德骑士团是最高等级的骑士团。汤姆，如果我们在这个播客节目里表现得好，我的意思是，我想从来没有哪个历史学家获得过加德勋章吧？有过吗？丘吉尔获得了加德勋章。我想约翰·梅杰也有。如果约翰·梅杰都有加德勋章，那你完全可以合理地追求一下。难道我们不能利用一下这个播客吗？当然可以。
So the Order of the Garter has been founded by Edward III at the absolute height of the Black Death. So St. George's Day, 1349. And Edward has been advised by his physicians to socially distance. Right. So, you know, Edward, however, is very much not the kind of guy I think who would have worn a mask. Yeah. He's a partying in Downing Street kind of fellow, isn't he? He very much is. And his response to this advice from his physicians
所以，加德骑士团是由爱德华三世在黑死病最猖獗的顶峰时期创立的。也就是1349年的圣乔治节。当时爱德华被他的御医建议要保持社交距离。没错。所以，（你知道的）不过爱德华绝不是那种会戴口罩的人。他属于那种在唐宁街开派对的家伙，对吧？他确实是这样的人。面对御医
to socially distance is to hold an absolutely massive tournament and invite everybody to it. That's actually Novak Djokovic type behavior. Yes. So this is what's going on on St. George's Day, a massive tournament, loads of ladies, loads of knights. And this is when he introduces the Order of the Garter. Right. And what this does absolutely brilliantly and much more effectively than the Order of the Star is to fuse the Arthurian with a massive celebration of military victory. So on the Arthurian level, the fact that it's held at Windsor is really significant
关于保持社交距离的建议，他的回应是举办一场规模空前盛大的比武大会，并邀请所有人参加。这其实就是诺瓦克·德约科维奇式的行为。没错。这就是圣乔治节当天正在发生的事情：一场盛大的比武大会，无数的贵妇，无数的骑士。正是在这个时候，他推出了加德骑士团。对。而这所做到的事情极其精彩，比星空骑士团有效得多，那就是将亚瑟王传奇与对军事胜利的盛大庆祝完美融合。所以在亚瑟王传奇的层面上，它选择在温莎举行具有极其重要的意义，
because Windsor is thought to have been founded by Arthur. And I think I said in a previous episode that when Edward first starts ruling in his own name, one of the first things he does is go to Glastonbury. And he then comes back and he starts building Windsor own name, one of the first things he does is go to Glastonbury. And he then comes back and he starts building Windsor. So the heart of Windsor Castle now, where the royal family still live, is the portion of the castle built by Edward III, basically to look like Camelot. So it's a kind of Arthurian fantasy. The tournament that he holds when he's meant to be socially distancing, it's absolutely modelled on the tournaments that Arthur holds. People praise and celebrate, say, Queen Philippa as a new Guinevere.
因为温莎被认为是亚瑟王建立的。我想我在前一集里说过，当爱德华开始以自己的名义独立执政时，他做的第一件事就是去格拉斯顿伯里。然后他回来开始修建温莎。以自己的名义执政时，他做的第一件事就是去格拉斯顿伯里。然后他回来开始修建温莎。所以今天皇室成员依然居住的温莎城堡的核心部分，就是由爱德华三世建造的那部分，其外观基本上就是为了模仿卡米洛特。所以这是一种亚瑟王式的幻想。他在本该保持社交距离时举办的比武大会，完全是以亚瑟王举办的比武大会为蓝本的。人们称赞并庆祝菲利普王后为新一代的桂妮维亚。
And the whole scene is, it's all about spectacle, dazzle, illusion, suspense. It's brilliantly done. But it's also about reclaiming military glory. You mentioned the garter. So the motto, Oni sua qui mal y pense, evil be to he who thinks it. And the joke in 1066 and all that is, honey, your garter's fallen off. So the story that comes to be told is that there is a lady, some say the Countess of Salisbury, and her garter drops off and Edward nobly hands it back to her.
整个场景充满了视觉奇观、耀眼的光芒、幻觉和悬念。做得非常出色。但它同时也关乎重塑军事荣耀。你提到了加德（吊袜带）。所以它的座右铭是：“心怀恶念者必受其殃”（Honi soit qui mal y pense）。在《1066年及所有那历史》中的那个笑话是：“亲爱的，你的吊袜带掉下来了。”于是流传开来的故事是：有一位女士——有人说是索尔兹伯里伯爵夫人——她的吊袜带掉了下来，爱德华高尚地把它捡起来还给了她，
And this is what he says. But this is a late story. And it's much likelier that that motto is the motto that Edward was using on the Cressy campaign. So everything that he was doing on the Cressy campaign was for the cause of legitimacy and God is basically the spin. And the garter in the 14th century, much more than in the 15th century, is actually associated with military figures rather than with women. And it's particularly associated with Edward's most formidable lieutenant, the Earl of Lancaster, who shortly after becomes the Duke of Lancaster, who is very much the leading English commander. He's led four wars in Scotland, in Gascony, he was at Sluice, he was at Calais, and he is enrolled as
并且说了这句话。但这其实是一个后世才出现的故事。更有可能的情况是，这句座右铭是爱德华在克雷西战役期间一直在使用的口号。因此，他在克雷西战役中所做的一切都是为了正统性，而上帝基本上就是他们的一种舆论宣传（spin）。在14世纪，吊袜带比在15世纪时更多地与军事人物联系在一起，而不是与女性联系在一起。它尤其与爱德华最令人生畏的副手兰开斯特伯爵（不久后成为兰开斯特公爵）紧密相连，后者无疑是英国军队的核心统帅。他在苏格兰、加斯科尼领导过四次战争，参加过斯鲁伊斯战役和加来围城战，并被招录为
the second knight of the order. And he is a guy who is particularly associated with a military garter. So that's the likeliest explanation for it. So he is enrolled in it. Edward is obviously, he's presiding over it. The Black Prince is enrolled in it. 26 in all, most of whom participated in the Crecy campaign. Among them, I'm proud to say, Sir Thomas Holland. Tom Holland. Yeah. So that's great. So I wouldn't be the first Tom Holland to be enrolled in it. No, you wouldn't. That's something. And also the guy who, again, from childhood was always my chivalric hero,
该骑士团的第二位骑士。他是一个与军事吊袜带有着特殊渊源的人。所以这才是最合理的解释。因此他加入了骑士团。爱德华显然是它的主持者。黑太子也加入了。总共26人，其中大多数人都参加了克雷西战役。在他们当中，我很自豪地说，有托马斯·霍兰德爵士。汤姆·霍兰德。没错。所以太棒了。那我可不是第一个加入它的汤姆·霍兰德了。不，你不是。这倒也是个亮点。而且还有那个人——同样，从小到大他一直都是我的骑士偶像，
who is, I think, the English equivalent to Geoffrey de Charny. Yeah. It's a man called Sir John Shandos. Okay. Now, tell us about Sir John. I know you love him. Well, you should know about him. You've been reading Sir Nigel.
我认为他就是英国版的热奥弗鲁瓦·德·沙尔尼。没错。他是一个名叫约翰·钱多斯爵士的人。好了。现在，给我们讲讲约翰爵士吧。我知道你很崇拜他。好吧，你该了解他一下。你一直在读《骑士奈杰尔》。
Sir Nigel becomes the squire to Sir John Shandos. Yeah. And John Shandos is, again, like Geoffrey de Charny, he's a younger son who rises to become one of the great chivalric and military figures in England and indeed in Europe. And it's that fusion of the chivalric and the military that is the key to his success. And he's the warrior who had, at Sluice, he'd landed and kind of reconnoitered the French fleet and reports back to Edward what it is, so kind of very brave. He'd stood beside the Black Prince, Cressy.
奈杰尔爵士成了约翰·钱多斯爵士的随从。没错。而约翰·钱多斯，就像热奥弗鲁瓦·德·沙尔尼一样，也是一个年轻的次子，最终崛起成为英国乃至整个欧洲最伟大的骑士和军事人物之一。正是这种骑士精神与军事才能的融合，构成了他成功的关键。他就是那个在斯鲁伊斯战役中登陆并侦察了法国舰队、向爱德华汇报情况的勇士，可以说是极其勇敢。他曾在克雷西战役中陪伴在黑太子身旁。
So Frassard describes him as a man who was wise and full of wiles and he's also a man of great sophistication charisma he's very fond of music very fond of dancing I mean he's absolutely a class act yeah and he comes to serve the black prince as his right-hand man he's both friend and military advisor and the black prince he's not oversold is he Tom is he is he as dashing and as gallant as I remember from my childhood textbooks? So there's debate about how the Black Prince, Edward of Woodstock, comes to get the soubriquet, the Black Prince. Some say it's because of his armour, which might be possible. Others say that it's because of his reputation in France, which is a dark one. He is a hard, hard man. But that kind of hardness isn't necessarily to his disrepute.
所以傅华沙（Froissart）将他描述为一个聪明且足智多谋的人，同时他也极具风度与个人魅力，非常喜欢音乐和舞蹈——我的意思是，他绝对是顶尖高手。没错。他前来担任黑太子得力的左右手，既是朋友又是军事顾问。而黑太子，他并没有被过分神化吧，汤姆？他真的像我儿时教科书里记的那样意气风发、英勇潇洒吗？关于黑太子伍德斯托克的爱德华是如何得到“黑太子”这个绰号的，一直存在争议。有人说是因为他的盔甲，这确实有可能。另一些人则说是因为他在法国那令人闻风丧胆的名声，那是一个阴暗的名声。他是个极其冷酷无情的人。但这种冷酷并不一定意味着他的声誉受损。
Yeah, we haven't come here to slag off the Black Prince, Tom. If you told me that would happen in this podcast, I would never agree to do it. Dominic, wait, wait, wait. Because again, chivalry in the 14th century, just as it perfectly entitles you to employ kind of Odyssean schemes and wheezes, it doesn't prohibit you from essentially committing what today we would describe as war crimes. Okay, that's good. So the Black Prince, he's still very young at this point. He's kind of not yet in his 20s. He is celebrated across Europe already as the flower of chivalry, the young 16-year-old at Crecy who had won his spurs. But he also has a reputation for being a hard man.
没错，我们今天可不是来贬低黑态子的，汤姆。如果你早告诉我这会在播客里发生，我打死也不会答应来录节目。多米尼克，等等，等等，等等。因为同样地，14世纪的骑士精神，正如它完全赋予你采用奥德修斯式的诡计和谋略的权利一样，它也并不禁止你犯下我们今天所说的战争罪行。好吧，这倒是个好消息。所以黑太子，他在这个时候依然非常年轻。他甚至还不到二十岁。他在全欧洲已经作为骑士之花而闻名遐迩，那个在克雷西战役中赢得马刺的16岁少年。但他也以冷酷无情著称。
So by the time that the Order of the Garter is initiated, he's already the most famous knight in Christendom. And this has a polarizing effect in the way that spectators to the Hundred Years War understand the relative status of England and France. So England, this minnow, has really started to kind of bulk up. As I keep saying, that matters. And it matters as well, of course, that compared to Edward, John II rapidly comes to seem a complete loser. Edward's genius is for keeping his nobility close to him, making them his allies, making them his friends, band of brothers. That's what the Order of the Garter is all about. John has a genius for alienating his nobility. So the
因此，当加德骑士团成立时，他已经成了基督教世界中最著名的骑士。这在百年战争的旁观者眼中产生了一种两极分化的影响，改变了他们对英法相对地位的理解。所以英国这个弹丸小国，真的开始变得兵强马壮了。正如我一直在说的，这很重要。当然，与爱德华相比，约翰二世迅速显得像个彻头彻尾的失败者，这同样很重要。爱德华的天才之处在于他与贵族保持紧密联系，让他们成为自己的盟友、朋友和生死兄弟。这就是加德骑士团的全部意义所在。而约翰的天才之处则在于疏远他的贵族。所以
constable of France had been taken prisoner during the Cressy campaign. He gets ransomed, comes back. John immediately executes him. Okay. Yeah. And the reason that he does this is because he's become very Edward II and wants to appoint one of his favourites as constable. Yeah. A near relative of his called Charles.
法国的宫廷总管（constable）在克雷西战役期间被俘。他被赎回后回来了，约翰随即处决了他。好吧。是的。他这么做是因为他变得越来越像爱德华二世，想要任命他自己的一个宠臣担任总管。没错。一个与他关系密切的亲戚，名叫查尔斯。
So Charles de Spagna, Charles of Spain. And this justice and nobility in the reign of Edward II had resented these displays of favouritism. So now in France, they resent John's displays of favouritism. And what makes this all the more dangerous is that Edward III is not John's only rival for the French throne. Yeah, I felt the story was getting insufficiently complicated, Tom, and we needed more contenders. There is a third rival.
也就是查尔斯·德·斯帕尼亚（Charles de Spagna），即西班牙的查尔斯。在爱德华二世统治时期，英国的司法界和贵族曾对这种任人唯亲的炫耀感到愤慨。而现在在法国，他们也同样对约翰任人唯亲的表现感到愤慨。让这一切变得更加危险的是，爱德华三世并不是约翰争夺法国王位的唯一对手。是的，我觉得这个故事变得不够复杂了，汤姆，我们需要更多的竞争者。还有一个第三个竞争者。
Now, again, Dominic, you may remember that i flagged up oh god you did do you remember i flagged up the fact that there were these three contenders for the french throne there was edward iii there was philip of valois yeah and there was a third philip philip of evereau yeah and he gets married off to joan who was the four-year-old girl yeah so direct descendant of the Capetians. And Joan and Philip of Evere had married. And I said, the problem for the Valois will be if Joan then has a son. Don't tell me she did.
现在，同样地，多米尼克，你可能还记得我之前提到过——哦天哪，你确实提过——你还记得我曾指出过法国王位有这三位竞争者吗？有爱德华三世，有瓦卢瓦的腓力，没错，还有第三个腓力——埃夫勒的腓力（Philip of Evereux）。他被安排迎娶了那个四岁的小女孩，没错，卡佩王朝的直系后裔。于是琼和埃夫勒的腓力结婚了。当时我说过，对瓦卢瓦家族来说，麻烦就在于如果琼生了个儿子。别告诉我她生了。
And Joan, Joan does have a son. And this guy is also called Charles. Right. Charles de Navarre. Yeah. Charles de Navarre. Yeah. Charles of Navarre. He's very kind of, well, you've never seen The Simpsons, have you? Well, I can see your notes.
而琼，琼确实生了个儿子。这个人也叫查尔斯。没错。纳瓦拉的查尔斯（Charles de Navarre）。没错。纳瓦拉的查尔斯。没错。纳瓦拉的查尔斯。他给人的感觉非常……嗯，你从来没看过《辛普森一家》，对吧？好吧，我能看到你的笔记。
You've just written the words, Mr. Burns. Right. So you probably know what Mr. Burns looks like. He's like the caretaker or something, is he? Is he something of that ilk? No, he's the evil guy. He's the evil capitalist who owns the nuclear power station. Okay. Well, I've never seen The Simpsons.
你刚刚写下了“伯恩斯先生”这几个字。好吧。所以你大概知道伯恩斯先生长什么样。他是个看门人什么的吗？他是那种类型的人吗？不，他是那个大反派。他是那个拥有核电站的邪恶资本家。好吧。我从来没看过《辛普森一家》。
If you look at kind of portraits of of charles of navarre he he looks slight he looks vulpine he has kind of big glistening eyes he's a schemer he's a backstabber he's utterly unscrupulous and the measure of how bad he is yeah he's actually called charles the bad that was your name yeah well it's not a name, it's his nickname. Yeah. And basically, he's so bad that all he does is go around plotting and scheming. And it's unclear whether he wanted to become King of France or whether he's just doing it for the bants, whether he's doing it for the fun. He's kind of a Iago figure. Right. But basically, if there's a possibility to stir up trouble, he will take it. And so,
如果你看纳瓦拉的查尔斯的画像，他看起来身材瘦削，长着一张狐狸般的脸，有一双大而发光的眼睛。他是个阴谋家，是个背后捅刀子的人，完全没有道德底线。衡量他有多坏的标准是——他的绰号居然就叫“恶人查尔斯”（Charles the Bad）。那是你的名字吗？不，这不是名字，这是他的绰号。基本上，他坏到骨子里了，整天除了搞阴谋诡计什么都不做。目前还不清楚他是想当法国国王，还是纯粹为了恶作剧、为了好玩才这么做。他简直就像莎士比亚笔下的伊阿古那样的人物。好吧。但基本上，只要有挑起事端的机会，他就会抓住。因此，
he has a younger brother who he commissions to murder the constable, Charles de Spagna, who behaves very, very badly, lets himself down, grovels, begs for mercy. But no, he's exterminated. And so by doing this, Charles the Bad wins the support of all the nobility who had resented the constable. John II promptly confiscates all Charles the Bad's lands in Normandy. Charles enters into negotiations with the English. John II backs down. There's going to be a test, by the way, for listeners at the end of this.
他有一个弟弟，他指使弟弟去谋杀宫廷总管查尔斯·德·斯帕尼亚。那个总管表现得非常非常糟糕，表现得很掉价，奴颜婢膝地乞求饶命。但没用，他被消灭了。通过这样做，恶人查尔斯赢得了所有对总管心怀不满的贵族的支持。约翰二世随即没收了恶人查尔斯在诺曼底的所有领地。查尔斯开始与英国人进行谈判。约翰二世又退缩了。顺便说一句，节目最后会对听众进行一次测试。
Okay. Basically, it's very, very easy to keep track of because essentially, if you think that you know who Charles the Bad is backing in the Hundred Years' War, you've got it wrong because he will have changed sides. He's constantly changing sides. And so this is kind of creating further chaos in France, that the stability of the monarchy is now becoming severely rocked. And John, thick though he is, understands this. He appreciates that things are really bad for him. He really needs a treaty to try and sort Charles the Bad out, to try and put his rule on firmer foundations. And so because the Pope in Avignon is very much under the thumb of the French king, he's able to kind of basically push the papacy to try and really work towards creating a peace treaty between England and France. And Edward is very tempted by it. But in
好吧。基本上，这件事非常非常容易跟踪，因为如果你以为你知道恶人查尔斯在百年战争中支持谁，那你就猜错了，因为他随时会叛变。他一直在叛变。因此，这在法国造成了进一步的混乱，君主制的稳定性现在开始受到剧烈动摇。而约翰虽然很笨，但也意识到了这一点。他意识到自己的处境非常糟糕。他真的很需要一份条约来试图解决恶人查尔斯的问题，好让他的统治建立在更坚实的基础之上。于是，由于在阿维尼翁的教皇在很大程度上受制于法国国王，他能够基本上推动教廷全力致力于促成英法之间的和平条约。爱德华对此非常心动。但最终，
the end, he turns it down, partly because he doesn't trust the Pope, because he thinks the Pope is basically French. But also because Charles the Bad inevitably switches sides again, stabs John in the back, and promises to join the English with an army in Normandy. And so this is in 1355. So Edward thinks, well, this is too good an opportunity to miss. So he draws up plans for a triple invasion. He is going to cross to Calais. The Duke of Lancaster is going to cross to Normandy and meet Charles the Bad. The Black Prince is going to head to Gascony. So they draw up all these plans.
他拒绝了，部分原因是他不信任教皇，因为他认为教皇本质上是法国人。但也因为恶人查尔斯不可避免地再次叛变，从背后捅了约翰一刀，并承诺带着军队在诺曼底加入英军。这就是1355年的情况。所以爱德华觉得，这实在是一个不容错过的绝佳机会。于是他拟定了三路入侵的计划。他自己将渡海前往加来；兰开斯特公爵将渡海前往诺曼底并与恶人查尔斯会合；黑太子将前往加斯科尼。于是他们制定了所有这些计划。
They're ready to go when inevitably Charles the Bad switches sides again. Oh my word. And moves back, starts back, you know, gets reconciled to John. And he goes to the Louvre and he swears before John II that he had done nothing against the king that a loyal vassal might not properly do. I think Charles the Bad is coming out of this pretty badly, or well, depending on your view. Well, he's bad.
他们正准备出发时，恶人查尔斯不可避免地又一次叛变了。我的天哪。他又倒戈回去，开始回去（你知道的）与约翰和解。他前往卢浮宫，在约翰二世面前发誓说，他从未做过任何不符合忠诚臣子身份的事。我觉得恶人查尔斯在这件事里的表现简直糟透了，或者说妙透了，取决于你的看法。好吧，他就是个坏蛋。
Yeah. I mean, he's bad through and through. And so this is a problem because obviously now it's no good for Normandy because the Duke of Lancaster won't have a kind of open port that Charles the Bad would have provided. Edward decides that he's not going to go to Calais, but the Black Prince, he wants to have a crack at the French. He wants to have another go. So he goes anyway.
我的意思是，他从里到坏透了。所以这就成了个问题，因为显然现在诺曼底那边行不通了，因为兰开斯特公爵将无法获得恶人查尔斯本应提供的那座开放港口。爱德华决定他不去加来，但黑太子想要去跟法国人较量一番。他想再试一次。所以他还是去了。
So the 9th of September, 1355, he sets sail from Plymouth And he's got a large expeditionary force and he heads off for Gascony and a series of campaigns that will make him perhaps the most famous knight in English history. Oh, splendid. Well, let's find out what happens after the break. See you in a minute. I'm Marina Hyde.
因此，在1355年9月9日，他率领一支庞大的远征军从普利茅斯起航，驶向加斯科尼，开启了一系列将使他成为英国历史上最著名骑士的战役。太棒了。好吧，让我们休息一下，看看接下来会发生什么。一会儿见。我是玛丽娜·海德。
And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. welcome back to the rest is history we ended as we always like to on a cliffhanger which was the black prince sailing from plymouth for gascony on the 9th of september 1355 bound as tom told us
我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》。这是你们每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论以及八卦爆料节目。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉大家这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想收听无广告的音频、独家加更节目以及提前抢购现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的余烬》。我们一如既往地以一个悬念结束了上一段，那就是黑太子于1355年9月9日率领舰队从普利茅斯起航前往加斯科尼，正如汤姆告诉我们的那样，他注定要迎来
for a series of campaigns that would enshrine him. I think, Tom, not merely as the greatest knight in English history, but as the greatest knight of all time. In European history. Absolutely. So, Tom, he arrives in Bordeaux, 20th of September, 1355. He's got 2,220 men. And he's also got your friend, Sir John Chandos, guest star of Sir Nigel. He's there. So what happens next? Well, the moment the Black Prince arrives, he's not hanging around. He decides that he's going to go looting and pillaging across the south of France. This is the chevauchée, the kind of English knights on tour. And they're like
一系列将使他青史留名的战役。汤姆，我认为他不仅将成为英国历史上最伟大的骑士，还将成为有史以来最伟大的骑士。在欧洲历史上。绝对的。所以，汤姆，他在1355年9月20日抵达波尔多。他拥有2220名士兵。而且他身边还有你的朋友、《骑士奈杰尔》的客串明星——约翰·钱多斯爵士。他也在那里。那么接下来发生了什么？好吧，黑太子一到达，就一刻也没有闲着。他决定在法国南部到处烧杀抢掠。这就是骑兵劫掠战（chevauchée），英国骑士们的巡游之旅。他们就像
football hooligans leaving trail of chaos. And because John and his lieutenants are worried about the English landing in northern France, they haven't come south to confront the Black Prince. So basically, the south is relatively undefended. Black Prince is able to recruit maybe 4,000 or 5,000 gas gun troops. So he's got quite a large force. And the Black Prince moves at a terrifying speed, takes the French completely by surprise. He's able to ford rivers that have never been forded before and strikes deep into lands that haven't seen the English for
足球流氓一样留下一路混乱。而且由于约翰和他的将领们担心英军会在法国北部登陆，他们并没有南下与黑太子正面交锋。所以基本上，南部处于相对防备空虚的状态。黑太子得以招募了大约4000或5000名加斯科尼部队。所以他拥有一支相当庞大的军队。黑太子以惊人的速度推进，完全出乎法军意料地攻克了那些从未被涉足的河流，并深入到了自
decades, for many, many generations. And as a result of that, these are lands that are incredibly rich. They fully recovered from the Albigensian Wars that we talked about in a previous episode. So, Froissart, the great chronicler, describes them as being one of the fattest lands in the world. And this is a place of great cities, enormously prosperous. The English arrive outside Carcassonne and, in true English style, one of them describes it as being even better than York. Even better. Even better than York. The highest praise you can think to give it. And the Black Prince advances almost to the Mediterranean. And then by the end of November, he's back in Aquitaine.
几十年来，为许多许多代人。正因如此，这些土地极其富饶。它们从我们上一集讨论过的阿尔比十字军东征中完全恢复了过来。因此，伟大的编年史家富鲁萨尔将其描述为世界上最肥沃的土地之一。这是一个拥有伟大城市、极其繁荣的地方。英国人抵达卡尔卡松城外，带有典型的英国风格，其中一人将其形容为比约克还要好。还要好。比约克还要好。这是你能想到的给予它的最高赞誉。黑太子几乎一直推进到地中海。然后在11月底前，他回到了阿基坦。
And everyone who's gone with him comes back enormously rich. It's said that a thousand wagons piled high with loot. There's loads of prisoners who can be ransomed. It's been great fun. They've destroyed 500 villages. They've burned down a dozen towns. So Tom, I know we're a patriotic podcast, but I should interject at this point and say, so this is all being fought on French soil. And for ordinary people, the Hundred Years War is
所有跟他一起去的人回来时都变得极其富有。据说有一千辆大车装满了战利品。有成群结队的俘虏可以用来索取赎金。这非常有趣。他们摧毁了500个村庄。他们烧毁了十几个城镇。所以汤姆，我知道我们是一个爱国的播客，但我应该在这个时候插话并说，这一切都是在法国土地上进行的。对于普通人来说，百年战争是
just a terrible, terrible business. Am I right? It's awful. It's awful. And most of the chroniclers don't really dwell on that, but some of them do and in duke was frasar will for instance you know he will say these people were innocent and they're completely innocent yeah and it's part of the brutality of the chivalric code that they don't really count right peasant lives don't matter not really i mean you'll maybe say this is a silly comparison but the combination of plague and extreme violence being visited on unwitting peasant communities. Is there a hint of the Thirty Years' War about this, would you say? Perhaps in the long run, but at the moment, the Black Prince is very clearly playing a role
简直是一件可怕得不能再可怕的事情。我说的对吗？太可怕了。太可怕了。大多数编年史家其实并没有详细谈论这一点，但有些人写了，例如在富鲁萨尔的著作中，你知道，他会说这些人是无辜的，他们完全是无辜的，是的，这是骑士精神残酷性的一部分，他们并不真正算数，对吧？农民的生命不重要，真的不重要。我的意思是，你可能会说这是一个愚宜的比较，瘟疫和极端的暴力降临在不知情的农民社区上。这其中是不是有点三十年战争的影子，你会这么说吗？从长远来看也许有，但目前，黑太子非常明确地在扮演一个角色
both as the Prince of Wales, so the heir to the English throne, and as the Duke of Aquitaine. Okay. heir to the English throne and as the Duke of Aquitaine. So the sense of a war between England and France at this point is still pretty clear. So the confusion and chaos that you get in the Thirty Years' War, it hasn't yet manifested itself. So the Prince of Wales is in command of this campaign. It's not slipping his control. It's not anarchic. It's very focused. No. And so the scale of this chevauchée, he's penetrated hundreds of miles deep into French territory. No one has opposed him. And so it's a shattering blow to French self-confidence. So in that sense, this is an English success. One, therefore, that redounds to the glory,
既作为威尔士亲王（即英国王位的继承人），又作为阿基坦公爵。好的。英国王位继承人兼阿基坦公爵。因此，此时英国与法国之间战争的感觉仍然相当清晰。所以你在三十年战争中看到的混乱和无序，还没有显现出来。因此，威尔士亲王在指挥这场战役。它没有失控。它不是无政府状态的。它是非常专注的。不。因此，这次骑兵驰掠的规模，他深入法国领土数百英里。没有人抵抗他。因此，这对法国的自信心是一个毁灭性的打击。所以从这个意义上说，这是一场英国的胜利。因此，这不仅为黑太子带来了荣耀，
not just of the Black Prince, but of the English crown as well. And conversely, it's absolutely terrible for the image of John. And there are French lords who are starting to think, you know, he's awful. So there's a guy in Normandy, the Count of Arco, very significant Norman lord, who cries out, by the blood of Christ, this king is a worthless man and a bad ruler. He's not wrong. And of course, it doesn't help that you've got Charles the Bad being bad on the scene. So this is eminently exploitable by him.
不仅为黑太子，也为英国王室带来了荣耀。相反，这对约翰的形象来说绝对是糟糕透顶。有些法国领主开始觉得，你知道，他太糟糕了。所以在诺曼底有一个家伙，阿尔库伯爵，一个非常重要的诺曼领主，他大喊道：“凭着基督的鲜血，这个国王是一个毫无价值的人，也是个糟糕的统治者。”他没有说错。当然，这无济于事，因为你还有个“恶人查理”（Charles the Bad）在现场兴风作浪。所以这个人极大地可以被他所利用。
Just on Charles the Bad, his base is Navarre. Is that right? No, his base is actually Normandy. Oh, right. So he does have Navarre, but he has lands all over France and he's particularly strong in Normandy. And apart from his sort of pantomime badness, I mean, there must be some rationale behind his, is his thinking just protecting his own domain in kind of Normandy? Yeah, he wants to expand his domain. He wants
就“恶人查理”而言，他的大本营是纳瓦拉。是这样吗？不，他的大本营其实是诺曼底。哦，对。所以他确实拥有纳瓦拉，但在整个法国各地他都有土地，而且他在诺曼底特别强大。除了他那种像哑剧反派一样的邪恶之外，我的意思是，他的行为背后一定有什么逻辑吧，他的想法难道只是为了保护他在诺曼底的领地吗？是的，他想扩大他的领地。他想
to make himself the leading man in France and perhaps at some point encompass the crown. I mean, we don't know. I mean, he seems basically to have engaged in kind of schemes and plots in huge part just for the fun of it. I mean, there is a kind of Iago-esque quality to him, but he's very, very good at it. So not only does he start recruiting people like the Count of Arcaux to his cause, so leading Norman knights, Charles the Bad also manages to suborn the Dauphin, who infuriatingly and typically is also called Charles, Charles, who's very debt-ridden, very resentful of his father, as Dauphins tend to be. Basically, Charles the Bad gets the Dauphin on his side. Meanwhile, he is scheming with the Count of Arcaux and various
让自己成为法国的领军人物，或许在某个时候吞并王冠。我的意思是，我们不知道。我的意思是，他似乎基本上只是出于好玩而参与了各种阴谋诡计。我的意思是，他有一种伊阿古式的特质，但他非常非常擅长。因此，他不仅开始招募像阿尔库伯爵这样的人加入他的事业——也就是领导诺曼骑士，恶人查理还成功收买了一向令人恼火且典型地也被称为查尔斯的王太子——查尔斯背负着沉重的债务，对他的父亲充满怨恨，就像王太子们往往会做的那样。基本上，恶人查理把王太子拉到了他这一边。与此同时，他正与阿尔库伯爵以及其他各种
other noblemen to seize and murder the king. It's not entirely clear whether the Dauphin is privy to this. He probably isn't. But he does seem to have been complicit in a scheme to deprive John at the very least of his power, if not his life. So this is a crisis at the absolute heart of the French royal state. And it duly gets uncovered by John. And in April 1356, he arrives in Rouen, the capital of Normandy, where the Dauphin is hosting Charles the Bad, the Count of Arcaux, all the other conspirators. John marches in, accuses everybody there of treachery, has Charles the Bad arrested, taken away to Paris where he's put under lock and key. The other conspirators are executed, including the Count of Arcaux. Their heads are chopped off, their bodies are dragged to gibbets, hung up in chains, their heads stuck on lances. This, again, does
贵族密谋夺取并谋杀国王。目前尚不完全清楚王太子是否知情。他可能不知道。但他似乎确实参与了一项旨在剥夺约翰权力（如果不是剥夺他的生命的话）的计划。因此，这是法国王室核心的一场危机。而这理所当然地被约翰发现了。1356年4月，他抵达诺曼底首府鲁昂，王太子正在那里接待恶人查理、阿尔库伯爵以及所有其他阴谋者。约翰大步走进去，指控在场的所有人叛国，下令逮捕恶人查理，将其带到巴黎并锁起来。其他阴谋者被处决，包括阿尔库伯爵。他们的头颅被砍下，尸体被拖到绞刑架上，用铁链吊起，头颅被插在长矛上。这再次
nothing to improve John's image with the aristocracy in France. And Charles the Bad is one of these victims? No, Charles the Bad has been arrested and taken to Paris. So John is ready to kill the lower order and ability who've been conspiring against him, but he's still not ready to get rid of Charles the Bad because that would be a step too far. So that's very Game of Thrones. I mean, turning the sun against the fire, the plot, the conspirators. And presumably the consequence of that is a complete rift between Charles the Bad's people, the House of Navarre and the, what's the House of France? The Valois.
无助于改善约翰在法国贵族中的形象。而恶人查理就是这些受害者之一吗？不，恶人查理被捕并被带到了巴黎。所以约翰准备杀死那些一直在密谋反对他的下层阶级和贵族，但他仍然没有准备好摆脱恶人查理，因为那会走得太远。所以这非常像《权力的游戏》。我的意思是，让儿子对抗父亲，阴谋，阴谋者。据推测，其结果是恶人查理的人马——纳瓦拉家族与——法兰西家族是什么？瓦卢瓦家族。
The Valois. Sorry, the Valois. Well, exactly. So the House of Navarre The Valois. The Valois, sorry, the Valois. Well, exactly. So the House of Navarre then repudiates its loyalty to the French crown. And because they are the big players in Normandy, that plunges Normandy into chaos. And of course, it means that the House of Navarre is now in alliance with England, which opens the gates to an English expeditionary force, which in July 1356, duly lands at Cherbourg, led by the Duke of Lancaster.
瓦卢瓦家族。抱歉，瓦卢瓦家族。好吧，确实如此。所以纳瓦拉家族瓦卢瓦家族。瓦卢瓦家族，抱歉，瓦卢瓦家族。好吧，确切地说。因此，纳瓦拉家族随后否认了对法兰西王室的效忠。由于他们是诺曼底的大玩家，这使诺曼底陷入了混乱。当然，这也意味着纳瓦拉家族现在与英国结盟，这就为英国远征军打开了大门。1356年7月，在兰开斯特公爵的率领下，英国远征军如期在瑟堡登陆。
And the brothers and the heirs of all the noblemen in Normandy who had been executed by John a few months before do homage to Edward III, pledge loyalty to him. And the Duke of Lancaster, as English war leaders tend to do, goes on an enormous chevauchée across Normandy, obviously not targeting the properties of his new allies, but very much targeting royal properties, and then into Brittany. And then towards later August, he heads southwards towards Gascony, because meanwhile, while the Duke of Lancaster is spreading chaos in the north, the Black Prince is up to his tricks in the south. And he is heading northwards from Gascony towards the Loire.
几个月前被约翰处决的所有诺曼底贵族的兄弟和继承人向爱德华三世宣誓效忠。兰开斯特公爵像英国军事领袖通常做的那样，在诺曼底进行了一场大规模的骑兵驰掠，显然没有把他的新盟友的财产作为目标，而是极大地将王室财产作为目标，然后进入布列塔尼。随后在8月下旬，他向南朝着加斯科涅进发，因为与此同时，正当兰开斯特公爵在北方散播混乱时，黑太子正在南方耍他的花招。他正从加斯科涅向北朝着卢瓦尔河进发。
The Loire is the great river that divides the two halves of France. And so the aim is for these two great English armies led respectively by the Duke of Lancaster and by the Black Prince to meet at the Loire, gang up, and then just have all kinds of fun. So that's the plan. Now, obviously, for John, this is the crisis to end all crises. He knows that he cannot allow this to happen. And so he sends out summons, he raises, it said, all the flower of France. That's an exaggeration because there are lots of noblemen who don't come to his cause because they're actively hostile to him. Nevertheless, he raises a large force, probably the largest force that is seen in France in the 14th century. And it's personally led by the king, who as a token of his confidence takes with him all his crown jewels. I mean, whenever anyone does that before a battle, you just think, well, have you learned nothing from history?
卢瓦尔河是分割法兰西两部分的大河。因此，这两个由兰开斯特公爵和黑太子分别率领的伟大的英国军队的目标是在卢瓦尔河会合，联合起来，然后尽情地大干一场。这就是计划。现在，对约翰来说，这显然是空前绝后的危机。他知道他绝不能让这种情况发生。因此，他发出征召令，据说他集结了法兰西所有的精锐。这是一个夸张的说法，因为有许多贵族没有响应他的号召，因为他们对他充满敌意。尽管如此，他还是集结了一支庞大的军队，可能是14世纪在法国见过的最大的一支军队。这支军队由国王亲自率领，为了显示信心，他随身携带了所有的王冠珠宝。我的意思是，每当有人在战役前这样做时，你就会想，好吧，你难道从历史中没有学到任何教训吗？
Or maybe people who win battles also take their crown jewels, but their chroniclers just never record it. Okay. From Dominic's comment, listeners who don't know the result may have some kind of presentiment of what's going to happen. I should have said, if you don't want to know the result, look away now. Yeah, look away now. Yeah, look away now. He also takes with him all four of his sons, including the Dauphin, Charles, and his younger son, who inevitably is called Philip. So just to make things even more confusing. The lords, the knights, the princes who accompany him. I mean, there are more than enough to make a dazzling display. They're all carrying their penance, fluttering proudly in
或者也许赢得战斗的人也会带上他们的王冠珠宝，但他们的编年史家从来没有记录过这一点。好吧。从多米尼克的评论来看，不知道结果听众可能会对将要发生的事情有一种预感。我本应该说，如果你不想知道结果，现在就把视线移开。是的，把视线移开。是的，现在把视线移开。他还带上了他的所有四个儿子，包括王太子查尔斯，以及他的小儿子，不出意料地，他也叫菲利普。这只会把事情搞得更加混乱。随行的高官、骑士、王子。我的意思是，人数多到足以呈现出一场耀眼的展示。他们都拿着自己的饰带，在
the air. So it's a tremendous spectacle, this army as it moves. And of course, the greatest of all the flags, the war banners, is the Oriflame that we mentioned in the context of Crecy, the sacred banner born into battle by the French king. And the man who carries it into battle by the side of the king is France's most famous knight, Geoffrey de Charny. I presume the Order of the Star is out in most famous knight, Geoffrey de Charny. Oh, I'm presuming the order of the star is out in force for this, is it? I mean- The order of the star is absolutely out in force. And of course, they pledged never to run away.
空中骄傲地飘扬。因此，这支军队在行进时是一个极其壮观的景象。当然，所有旗帜、战旗中最伟大的是我们在克雷西战役背景下提到过的“黄金长剑旗”（Oriflaim），这是由法国国王带入战场的圣旗。在国王身旁将它带入战场的人是法国最著名的骑士——若弗鲁瓦·德·夏尔尼（Geoffroi de Charny）。我猜星月骑士团最著名的骑士若弗鲁瓦·德·夏尔尼出动了。哦，我猜星月骑士团为此全员出动了吗？我的意思是——星月骑士团绝对是全员出动。当然，他们发誓绝不逃跑。
No, they can't go backwards. Yeah, exactly. So hopes are very, very high in this great gathering that at last a French king will be able to corner an English army and wipe it out. And the news is brought that the Black Prince is approaching Loire. And of course, they have to cross the Loire if they're going to go northwards and meet with the Duke of Lancaster. So the Black Prince sends his most trusted lieutenant, Sir John Chandos, to lead an advance party to try and find a ford. They reach what they think is going to be a ford,
不，他们不能后退。是的，确实如此。因此，在这个盛大的集会上，人们抱有非常非常高的期望，希望法国国王最终能够将英军逼入绝境并将其全歼。消息传来，黑太子正在接近卢瓦尔河。当然，如果他们要向北进并发与兰开斯特公爵会合，他们就必须穿过卢瓦尔河。于是，黑太子派出了他最信任的副将约翰·钱多斯爵士（Sir John Chandos）率领先头部队去寻找一个浅滩。他们到达了他们认为应该是浅滩的地方，
and they find it guarded by French troops. Sir John Chandos, because he's tremendously cool, beats them off easily. But he finds that the river is too swollen to cross. There's been a lot of rain. The Loire is very, very swollen. So the Black Prince and his army start to move along the south bank of the Loire,
却发现那里有法国军队把守。约翰·钱多斯爵士因为极其冷静，轻易地击退了他们。但他发现河水太涨，无法渡过。下过很多雨。卢瓦尔河水涨得非常非常高。于是，黑太子和他的军队开始沿着卢瓦尔河的南岸移动，
trying to find a crossing. But as it happened on the Crecy campaign, all the bridges have been cut and they can't find a way to get over the Loire. News then reaches him that the French king is approaching him with a massive army and the black prince does not have enough men with him really to meet this huge army in battle. He really, really needs to join up with Duke of Lancaster. And so he is sending scouts out frantically trying to find the Duke of Lancaster's expedition. Meanwhile, on the 10th of September, the French have reached Blois on the Loire where a bridge has been held for them and they cross it. 11th of September, they're closing in on the Black Prince and the Black Prince is informed that this vast French army is now 10 miles from him, and he still can't find the Duke of Lancaster. And he learns on the same day
试图寻找一个渡口。但正如在克雷西战役中发生的那样，所有的桥梁都被切断了，他们找不到过卢瓦尔河的方法。随后消息传到他那里，法国国王正带着庞大的军队向他逼近，而黑太子身边的兵力根本不足以与这支庞大军队正面交锋。他真的、真的需要与兰开斯特公爵会合。因此，他疯狂地派出侦察兵，试图寻找兰开斯特公爵的远征军。与此同时，在9月10日，法军抵达了卢瓦尔河畔的布卢瓦，那里有一座桥为他们保留着，他们渡过了桥。9月11日，他们正在逼近黑太子，黑太子被告知这支庞大的法军现在距离他只有10英里，而他仍然找不到兰开斯特公爵。并且他在同一天得知
that the reason for this is that just as he can't get to the northern bank of the Loire, so the Duke of Lancaster can't get to the southern bank. So essentially they're separated. So the Black Prince retreats towards the town of Poitiers, which is just south, southwards of where he'd been. He stops there to wait to see if Lancaster will be able to get across. As he halts there, the French army passes him about 10 miles to the east and then pivots westwards. Essentially, the road from Poitiers back to Gascony is cut off. Bad news for the Black Prince, Tom. So what's the Black Prince going to do?
原因在于，正如他无法到达卢瓦尔河北岸一样，兰开斯特公爵也无法到达南岸。所以本质上他们被隔开了。因此，黑太子向普瓦捷（Poitiers）镇撤退，该镇位于他先前所在位置的正南方。他在那里停下来，等待看看兰开斯特公爵是否能够过河。正当他在那里停下时，法军从他以东大约10英里处经过，然后向西转向。本质上，从普瓦捷返回加斯科涅的道路被切断了。这对黑太子来说是个坏消息，汤姆。那么黑太子打算怎么办？
He decides he has no choice really but to offer battle. And so rather than alert the French to this, he orders his troops to advance through a forest so that the French won't know that he's approaching. And on the 17th of September, a company of Gascons emerge from this forest, emerge from the wood. They stumble into the French rear guard and they route it. But of course, it's now the king and all the French command know that the English are basically within striking distance. There's no point in hiding in the wood anymore. So the 18th of September, the English emerge from the wood. And there's a hill, it's about five miles south of Poitiers, overlooking a village called Naye. And the Black Prince and Sir John Chandos occupy this, raise their banners, take possession of it.
他决定自己实在没有别的选择，只能迎战。因此，为了不惊动法军，他命令部队穿过一片森林推进，这样法军就不会知道他在逼近。9月17日，一队加斯科涅人从这片森林中钻出来，从树林中走了出来。他们意外撞上了法国后卫部队并将其击溃。当然，现在国王和所有法国指挥官都知道英军基本上在打击范围内了。没必要再躲在树林里了。因此在9月18日，英军从树林中走了出来。有一座山，大约在普瓦捷以南五英里处，俯瞰着一个叫内（Naye）的村庄。黑太子和约翰·钱多斯爵士占领了这里，高举旗帜，占领了该地。
But their situation is very bad because they don't have any food and they don't have any water. Plus, they're pretty shattered. I was going to say they've been marching for hundreds of miles. And also the effort of pulling their wagons through the woods has been stressful. So at this point, the English and the French are staring at each other. Ambassadors from the Pope step in and they're led by a cardinal, the cardinal of Perigord. And he senses that the English situation is very, very weak. And so perhaps this is an opportunity to lean on the Black Prince and get him to accept terms that would then also be acceptable to the French king. And the Black Prince's situation is so grim that basically he says he is willing to negotiate.
但他们的处境非常糟糕，因为他们没有食物，也没有水。此外，他们精疲力竭。我正要说他们已经行军了数百英里。而且把大车拉过树林的努力也让他们压力重重。此时，英军和法军正互相瞪着对方。教皇的使节介入了，他们由一位红衣主教率领，即佩里戈尔红衣主教。他感觉到英军的处境非常非常虚弱。因此，这或许是一个向黑太子施压并让他接受也能被法国国王接受的条款的机会。黑太子的处境如此严峻，以至于他基本上表示愿意谈判。
But John isn't because he feels that he has the English absolutely captured. This is his chance to finish the most once and for good. So the Cardinal's mediation efforts fail and loads of his entourage then go off and join the French, which only confirms the English suspicions of what kind of papal ambassadors they're up to. And so basically becomes pretty certain that the following day, which is the 19th of September, there is going to be a battle. Unless, of course, by some miracle, the Prince of three battalions so the first line is commanded by the Dauphin yeah but he has you know he's still very young John doesn't entirely trust him so he has at his right hand a Scotsman Lord of Douglas that is disappointing in obedience to the old alliance has come to France with a contingent of Scots knights and warriors so they're in the front line. And
但约翰不愿意，因为他觉得他已经彻底抓住了英国人。这是他一劳永逸地解决这个问题的机会。因此，红衣主教的调解努力失败了，他的随从中有许多人随后离开并加入了法军，这只会证实英国人对这帮教皇使者意图的怀疑。因此，基本上可以确定，第二天，也就是9月19日，将有一场战斗。除非，当然，通过某种奇迹，三支部队构成了——因此第一线由王太子指挥，是的，但他还有，你知道，他仍然很年轻，约翰并不完全信任他，所以在他右手边有一个苏格兰人，道格拉斯勋爵，那令人失望的是，为了服从老同盟，他带着一队苏格兰骑士和勇士来到了法国，所以他们在前线。而且
because they are used to fighting the English, they suggest to the French that they dismount from their horses. In other words, that they don't launch a kind of full-on cavalry charge, because this would not be, you know, otherwise they risk a repeat of the Battle of Crecy. And this is advice that John is prepared to accept. The second line is commanded by the Duke of Orléans, brother of the king, and two of the Dauphin's younger brothers are there. And the third line, it's the king with Geoffrey de Charny and the Oriflame and his youngest son, Philip.
因为他们习惯了与英国人作战，他们向法国人建议从马上下来。换句话说，他们不要发动那种全力以赴的骑兵冲锋，因为这不会是，你知道，否则他们会冒着重演克雷西战役的风险。约翰准备接受这个建议。第二线由国王的弟弟奥尔良公爵指挥，王太子的两个弟弟也在那里。第三线是国王带着若弗鲁瓦·德·夏尔尼、黄金长剑旗和他的小儿子菲利普。
Okay. So that's their battle line. And then having drawn it up, there's actually a delay because suddenly they start to think, well, perhaps we shouldn't fight a battle. Perhaps we should just stay here and starve the english out that would be the obvious yeah thing to do meanwhile the black prince has decided that he is going to try and retreat and this of course is an incredibly difficult maneuver because it requires moving slowly backwards through the wood and not alerting the french but it's impossible not to alert the French. And so
好的。这就是他们的战线。然后排好阵势后，实际上出现了耽搁，因为他们突然开始想，嗯，也许我们不应该打仗。也许我们应该就待在这里把英国人饿死，这显然是，是的，该做的事。与此同时，黑太子决定他要尝试撤退，这当然是一个极其困难的机动，因为它需要通过树林缓慢地向后移动而不惊动法军，但要不惊动法军是不可能的。因此
not all the French are on foot. Some are still on horseback and they notice the retreat and they're so excited by this that they immediately launch a charge. So they go careering up the hill, wiped out by the English archers. When the first French line sees this, they think, oh, we better march to the rescue. And so they start marching up the hill. And so the battle is joined and the fight goes on for two hours, but the French can't break through the English lines. And after two hours fighting, the French line breaks. The Dauphin has to be hurried away because obviously they don't want to risk him being captured. As the first line starts moving away, the second line commanded by the Duke of Orléans thinks that the battle is
并非所有法军都在步行。有些人仍然骑着马，他们注意到了撤退，对此感到异常兴奋，以至于他们立即发起了冲锋。于是他们狂奔上山，被英国弓箭手全歼。当第一支法军看到这一幕时，他们想，哦，我们最好去救援。于是他们开始向山上开进。战斗就这样打响了，厮杀了两个小时，但法军无法突破英国人的防线。经过两个小时的战斗，法军防线崩溃了。王太子不得不被仓促带走，因为显然他们不想冒他被俘的风险。当第一线开始撤离时，由奥尔良公爵指挥的第二线认为战斗已经
lost. And so he starts withdrawing. And as he goes, he's taking two of the Dauphin's younger brothers with him. So it's a kind of chaos of confusion and misunderstanding. And John the King in the third line sees this and is humiliated and ashamed and mortified and is absolutely determined to save French honor. And of course, as the head of the Order of the Star, there's no prospect that he can possibly retreat. No cracking, no. And so instead, he advances.
失败了。于是他开始撤退。在他离开时，他带走了王太子的两个弟弟。所以这是一片混乱和误解的混沌。第三线的国王约翰看到这一幕，感到羞辱、羞耻和万分尴尬，决心誓死捍卫法兰西的荣誉。当然，作为星月骑士团的团长，他绝不可能有退缩的可能。没有崩溃，不。相反，他向前推进了。
And by this point, he's absolutely in with a shout because the English archers have run out of arrows. They're tired. And basically, all the greatest knights in France are with the king, all the members of the Order of the Star. And so the fighting is incredibly desperate, but with the result of the battle still absolutely hanging in the balance, one of the English captains notices that there's an opportunity for a flanking maneuver. So he takes his men, he breaks from
到了这个时候，他绝对有一拼之力，因为英国弓箭手的箭已经射光了。他们累了。基本上，法国最伟大的骑士都和国王在一起，星月骑士团的所有成员都在。因此，战斗极其绝望，但随着战斗的结果仍然悬而未决，一名英国队长注意到这是一个侧翼包抄的机会。于是他带着部下，从
the line and he moves around and starts to attack the French in their rear. This generates a kind of sense of chaos and panic in the French army. At this point, the Black Prince and Chandos appreciate that this is the moment. This is their opportunity. So they order all their knights to get on their horses. The horses have been kept back in reserve to get on their horses and, again, to launch another kind of flanking maneuver on the other wing. And the French end up surrounded and essentially those who don't flee are annihilated. And Frassard describes the culmination of the battle. So he says, the pursuit of the routed
防线上脱离并移动到后方，开始攻击法兰西军队的后方。这在法军中引发了一种混乱和恐慌感。此时，黑太子和钱多斯意识到时机已到。这是他们的机会。于是他们命令所有骑士上马。马匹一直被留在后备队中，现在上马，再次在另一翼发动另一种侧翼包抄。法军最终被包围，基本上那些没有逃跑的人都被消灭了。富鲁萨尔描述了战斗的高潮。他说，对溃逃的
French went on as far as the walls of Poitiers where there was a fearful slaughter of men and horses. The inhabitants of Poitiers shut the gates and refused to let anyone in. Consequently, a horrible scene of killing and maiming took place in the road and before the main gate. The French surrendered at the mere sight of an Englishman, and some of these archers and others had four, five, or six prisoners each. Never before had there been so disastrous a rout. But members of the Order of the Staff, to give them credit, they refused to retreat. Geoffrey de Charny is killed holding the or holding the aura flame so his body is found with his fingers tight around the staff of the flag yeah and climactically triumphantly for the english disastrously for the french john ii is taken prisoner and this is actually the climax of sir nigel. So in the novel, it's Sir Nigel who captures the French king.
法军的追击一直持续到普瓦捷的城墙下，那里发生了人马的惨烈屠杀。普瓦捷的居民关上城门，拒绝让任何人进入。因此，在道路上和正门前发生了一幕可怕的杀戮和残害场景。法军一看到英国人就投降了，其中一些弓箭手和其他人每个人都有四、五个或六个俘虏。在此之前，从未有过如此灾难性的溃败。但星月骑士团的成员，平心而论，他们拒绝撤退。若弗鲁瓦·德·夏尔尼在手握黄金长剑旗时战死，人们发现他的手指紧紧扣在旗杆上。是的，对英国人来说是高潮迭起的胜利，对法国人来说则是灾难性的，约翰二世被俘虏。这实际上是《尼尔爵士》的高潮。所以在小说中，是尼尔爵士俘虏了法国国王。
So kind of stirring moment. And it's an amazing victory won by the Black Prince and Sir John Shandos completely against the odds. A French chronicler describing the performance of both men in this battle, described them as being courageous and cruel as lions. As well as the king, his son Philip is taken prisoner, 2,000 other noblemen. And as you hinted, Dominic,
这是一个令人振奋的时刻。这是黑太子和约翰·钱多斯爵士在完全处于劣势的情况下取得的惊人胜利。一位法国编年史家在描述两人在这场战役中的表现时，称他们“勇敢而残忍如狮子”。除了国王，他的儿子菲利普以及其他2000名贵族也被俘虏。正如你所暗示的，多米尼克，
the crown jewels fall into the hands of the black prince. And so this is an amazing victory. The news is sent back to Edward III, who very, very piously declares, we take no pleasure in the slaughter of men, but we rejoice in God's bounty. We look forward to a just and early peace. So that men, but we rejoice in God's bounty. We look forward to a just and early peace. So that's very nice. Very nice. And John is kept with the Black
王冠珠宝落入了黑太子手中。所以这是一场惊人的胜利。消息传回给爱德华三世，他非常非常虔诚地宣称：“我们对人的屠杀不感到高兴，但我们为上帝的恩赐感到高兴。我们期待一个公正而持久的和平。”所以人，但我们为上帝的恩赐感到高兴。我们期待一个公正而持久的和平。所以这很好。非常好。约翰与黑
Prince in Bordeaux over winter. He's looked after very well. And then the following spring, the Black Prince takes John back to London. And on the 24th of May, they enter the capital, the Black Prince riding on a horse that is deliberately shorter than the horse that the French King is riding on. So that at least the French King is given the dignity that is his status as the greatest king in Europe. All the principal prisoners as well. And such are the crowds that come to witness this spectacle, that it takes the Black Prince and his royal prisoner three hours to cross the city. Imagine being in the crowd for that song.
太子一起在波尔多过冬。他被照顾得很好。第二年春天，黑太子把约翰带回了伦敦。5月24日，他们进入了首都，黑太子骑着一匹故意比法国国王骑的马矮的马。这样至少给予了法国国王作为欧洲最伟大国王应有的尊严。所有主要俘虏也是如此。前来见证这一奇观的人群如此之多，以至于黑太子和他的皇室囚犯花了三个小时才穿过这座城市。想象一下在那首歌的乌合之众中会是什么感觉。
That would be, oh, that would be brilliant. Wouldn't it be great? I mean, it would be like, you know, winning the World Cup and going on an open tour bus. It's basically. Well, or capturing President Macron leading him through the streets of London. Yeah. And all the, yeah, all the Assemb nationales yeah i'm sure the i'm sure the crowds in london would really behave themselves anyway but actually i mean edward
那将是，哦，那将是极好的。不是很棒吗？我的意思是，那就像，你知道，赢得世界杯并乘坐敞篷观光巴士一样。基本上是这样。嗯，或者俘虏马克龙总统带领他穿过伦敦街头。是的。还有，是的，所有的国民议会，是的，我确信伦敦的市民真的会表现得很好，无论如何。但实际上，爱德华
does behave himself quite well and they give him um the great palace of the savoy where the savoy hotel stands now and which had been built by the duke of lancaster with all the loot he's got from all his various french prisoners so yeah that's where the French king is allowed to stay and to set up his household. It's where the ransom negotiations begin. And meanwhile, out in London, across the nation, there is rejoicing. And the herald of Sir John Chandos sums it up. He writes, there was dancing, there was hunting, there was hawking. There were great jousts and banquets
表现得确实挺好，他们给了他萨伏伊大宫，也就是现在萨伏伊酒店所在地，这座宫殿是兰开斯特公爵用他从各种法国俘虏那里掠夺的战利品建造的。所以，是的，法国国王就被允许呆在那里并建立他的宅邸。赎金谈判就是在那里面开始的。与此同时，在伦敦郊外，在全国各地，都在欢庆。约翰·钱多斯爵士的传令官总结了这一切。他写道：“有舞蹈，有狩猎，有驯鹰。有盛大的比武和宴会
and it was all as at the court of king arthur what a note on which to end but tom i have a nasty feeling because there's another episode to come afraid there is a nasty feeling that it's all going to go horribly wrong in the next episode or horribly right if you're our producer theo who's been listening to this in a state of agony, moaning and groaning about French bashing. When you say Theo, Theo. Well, yeah. I mean, if I tell you that his name is Theo Young-Smith, you can gauge from that just how French he is.
这一切就像在亚瑟王的宫庭里一样。”多么棒的收场白啊。但汤姆，我有一种不祥的预感，因为还有一集要播。恐怕是的，有一种不祥的预感，下一集一切都会变得一团糟——如果你是我们的制作人西奥的话，他一直在痛苦的状态中聆听，抱怨和哀叹对法国的抨击，那么一切都会变得非常正确。当你说西奥时，西奥。好吧，是的。我的意思是，如果我告诉你他的名字叫西奥·杨-史密斯，你就可以从名字中看出他有多法国了。
He really is. Yeah, exactly. But he makes great play with being both French and Scottish. So I'm afraid that the result of the Battle of Poitiers. He's the embodiment of the old alliance, Tom. Yeah, he is. I'm amazed we have result of the battle of Poitiers He's the embodiment of the old alliance Yeah he is I'm amazed we have him around Alright, on that bombshell, we will be back on Thursday
他真的是。是的，完全如此。但他极力标榜自己既是法国人又是苏格兰人。所以恐怕普瓦捷战役的结果。他是老同盟的化身，汤姆。是的，他是。我很惊讶我们身边竟然有。结果普瓦捷战役。他是老同盟的化身，是的，他是。我很惊讶我们身边有他。好吧，在这个重磅炸弹下，我们周四会回来
you will of course be able to listen to it now if you're a member of the Rest Is History Club Some people say the Rest Is History Club is actually better than being in the Order of the Garter It's certainly a lot better than being in the Order of the Star because we do allow you to go backwards. Yes we do. If you're a member of the Rest Is History Club, crack on, listen to the fourth episode.
如果你是“历史其余部分俱乐部”的会员，你现在当然可以收听它。有人说“历史其余部分俱乐部”实际上比加入嘉德勋章还要好。它肯定比加入星月骑士团好得多，因为我们确实允许你倒退。是的，我们允许。如果你是“历史其余部分俱乐部”的会员，那就继续，收听第四集。
If you're not, sign up at restishistorypod.com. And either way, we'll see you for the next episode. Goodbye. Au revoir. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com.
如果不是，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。无论如何，我们下一集见。再见。再见。感谢收听《历史的其余部分》。若要收听独家节目、提前收听、无广告收听并加入我们的聊天社群，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。
That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com.
那是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐的其余部分》。这是您每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和一丝娱乐圈八卦的固定节目。在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开娱乐的帷幕，告诉您这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果您想要无广告收听、独家节目并提前购买现场演出门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。
That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
那是 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击字幕中的任何句子即可发表评论。